I'm Roman Mars from 99% Invisible. And I'm Ben Brock Johnson from Endless Thread. And this is episode four of Hidden Levels, our show about how the world of video games has changed the world beyond video games. Roman, are you familiar with the concept of a video game trailer? Well, I've never seen one, but I'm guessing it's just like a movie trailer, but for video games. Ding, ding, ding. And as advertisements for video games, these things work on me. I spend a lot of time watching them.
我是来自《99%隐形》的罗曼·马尔斯。我是来自《无尽线程》的本·布洛克·强森。这里是《隐藏关卡》第四集，我们在这档节目中探讨电子游戏的世界如何改变了游戏之外的世界。罗曼，你熟悉“电子游戏预告片”这个概念吗？嗯，我从来没看过，但我猜它就像电影预告片一样，只不过是为游戏拍的。答对了。作为游戏的广告，这些东西对我很管用。我花了很多时间看它们。
You know, the first video game trailer I remember, the one that got me to spend way too much time in high school, putting off my homework and instead booting up, I think, Windows 95 to play a video game, was for Warcraft to Tides of Darkness. The once mighty army of Azarov lay among the blackened and charred remains of stormwind key. Those that escaped fled across the Great Sea, bringing tales of the suffering they had faced at the hands of the orkish hordes. The game was awesome, if pretty two-dimensional. But the trailer, the trailer was more three-dimensional. It actually doesn't look that much like the game. It had these kind of sweeping camera angles in it, the music that was super epic and kind of told its own story just like a good movie trailer does. that all felt new and different to me in the video game world.
你知道，我记忆中第一个电子游戏预告片——那个让我花大量时间在高中里逃避家庭作业，转而启动——我想是 Windows 95 来玩电子游戏的预告片——是《魔兽争霸2：黑暗之门》。艾泽拉斯曾经强大军队躺在暴风城要塞焦黑的废墟之中。那些逃脱的人穿过了大海，带来了他们所遭受的兽人部族残酷折磨的传闻。这个游戏太棒了，尽管画面相当二维。但那个预告片，那个预告片更有三维感。它实际上看起来并不太像那个游戏。它里面有那种横扫的镜头角度，配乐超级史诗，就像一个好的电影预告片那样讲述着它自己的故事。在游戏世界里，这一切对我来说都显得那么新颖、与众不同。
So when I watch this, I mean, this really looks like a movie. It doesn't look like a video game. Right? It certainly doesn't look like a video game from 1995. Like the camera angles, the presentation, it's really cinematic. It almost seems like they're lying about the game you're about to play here anyway. But the key here is that this is all using the language of cinema, not the language of video games. That's right.
所以当我看到这个时，我的意思是，这看起来真像一部电影。它看起来不像一个电子游戏。对吧？它当然看起来不像 1995 年的电子游戏。比如镜头角度、表现形式，真的很有电影感。它几乎看起来就像他们在对你即将玩到的游戏撒谎一样。不过这里的关键在于，这完全使用的是电影的语言，而不是电子游戏的语言。没错。
And one of the big changes in the last few decades of games is that as two-dimensional game environments became three-dimensional Roman, graphics got better, game worlds became more open, video games didn't just get marketed like movies, they became more like movies themselves. Today, lots of Hollywood actors are in games, and many games have their own cinematographers. And today on Hidden Levels, we're going to talk about the increasingly blended worlds of games and movies, and the boom and bust's history of movies inside games. This episode is from 99PI contributor, Andrew Callow.
在过去几十年的游戏中，最大的变化之一是，随着二维游戏环境变成三维，罗曼，图形变得更好了，游戏世界变得更加开放，电子游戏不仅仅像电影一样被营销，它们本身就变得更像电影了。如今，许多好莱坞演员都在游戏中出演，许多游戏都有自己的电影摄影师。今天在《隐藏关卡》中，我们将讨论游戏和电影日益融合的世界，以及游戏内部电影的兴衰史。本期节目来自 99PI 的撰稿人安德鲁·卡洛。
In 2020, Sam Crane was feeling lost. He's a professional actor, and he had just booked the gig of a lifetime on London's West End. But when the pandemic hit, all the theaters shut down, and Sam was stuck, waiting for the world to reopen. He wasn't much of a video game person until he saw his son watching YouTube videos of people playing games. Then he realized there was a whole other world
2020 年，山姆·克兰感到很迷茫。他是一名专业演员，刚刚在伦敦西区接到了他一生中最好的演出工作。但当疫情来袭时，所有的剧院都关门了，山姆被困住了，只能等待世界重新开放。他对电子游戏不太感兴趣，直到他看到儿子在 YouTube 上看别人玩游戏的视频。然后他意识到，还有一个完全不同的世界
that hadn't shut down. Sam got a hold of his son's PlayStation and invited some friends to join him online. A lot of people found at that time that actually hanging out in those spaces is like really fun. Certainly when compared to like doing Zoom calls with friends or family.
没有关门。山姆拿到了他儿子的 PlayStation，并邀请了一些朋友在线加入他。当时很多人发现，实际上在这些空间里闲逛非常有趣。当然，与和朋友或家人进行 Zoom 通话相比更是如此。
At first, he was just having fun. But artistic inspiration struck when he entered the virtual world of Grand Theft Auto 5. If you're a parent that should send, shivers down your spine if you hear these three words. Grand Theft Auto. Now, if you don't know what Grand Theft Auto is,
起劲。但当他进入《侠盗猎车手5》的虚拟世界时，艺术灵感油然而生。如果你是父母，听到这三个词应该会不寒而栗。侠盗猎车手。现在，如果你不知道《侠盗猎车手》是什么，
it's only the most financially successful piece of entertainment ever. GTA is a video game in which you play as a game. who's trying to build a criminal empire. It's notorious for its extreme cartoonish violence and cheat code hacks for mini-games where your avatar can have sex with a stripper.
它简直是有史以来财务上最成功的娱乐作品。GTA 是一款电子游戏，你在其中扮演一个试图建立犯罪帝国的游戏角色。它以极端的卡通暴力和迷你游戏的秘籍作弊码而闻名，你的虚拟化身可以与脱衣舞娘发生性关系。
For a game so crass and content, the level of detail in Grand Theft Auto is breathtaking. From autumn leaves falling to the reflection of the sunset, glistening in ocean waves. In the city of San Andreas, where it all takes place, is so enormous you could spend eight. ages exploring and still not find everything.
对于一款如此粗俗和内容丰富的游戏来说，《侠盗猎车手》中的细节水平令人叹为观止。从飘落的秋叶到落日的倒影，在海浪中波光粼粼。一切发生所在的圣安地列斯市是如此巨大，以至于你可以花上八。辈子探索，却依然无法找到所有东西。
So it was tucked away in a hidden area of the map that Sam made a discovery which charted the course for the next several years of his life. In one fortuitous moment, he found an empty theater. Oh, look at this. It's like a massive kind of arena. This is a recording from Sam's gameplay. I wonder if you could actually stage something here.
因此，正是藏在地图的一个隐蔽区域里，山姆发现了一个重大秘密，为他未来几年的生活指明了方向。在一个幸运的时刻，他发现了一个空剧院。哦，看这个。这就像一个巨大的竞技场。这是山姆游戏过程的录像。我想知道你是否真的可以在这里上演点什么。
What, like a put on a play? Yeah. That first voice is Sam, and the second is Mark Oosterveen, Sam's friend, fellow actor, and his guide through the world of GTA. Sam and Mark decided to stage a play in the Grand Theft Auto Theater. And of course, our British friends obviously defaulted to Shakespeare, perhaps his most violent play, Hamlet. Now, GTA5 Online is full of other players, real people from around the world, that you can interact with.
什么，比如上演一出戏？是的。第一个声音是山姆，第二个是马克·奥斯特芬，山姆的朋友、同行演员，也是他在 GTA 世界里的向导。山姆和马克决定在《侠盗猎车手》剧院里上演一出戏。当然，我们的英国朋友显然默认选择了莎士比亚，也许是他最暴力的戏剧《哈姆雷特》。现在，GTA5 在线模式充满了其他玩家，来自世界各地的真实玩家，你可以与他们互动。
Sam and Mark decided to use this aspect of the game to their advantage, filling the cast of their Hamlet by auditioning strangers from the streets of San Andreas. Okay. Oh, look, we've got another audience member here. This is Hamlet. William Shakespeare's Hamlet. I just message everyone in the servers. I didn't know who they were. They're just random people.
山姆和马克决定利用游戏的这个方面为自己谋利，通过试镜圣安地列斯街头的陌生人来填补他们的《哈姆雷特》演员阵容。好的。哦，看，我们这里有另一个观众。这是哈姆雷特。威廉·莎士比亚的《哈姆雷特》。我只是给服务器里的每个人发了消息。我不知道他们是谁。他们只是随机的人。
people in the server say, hey, we're doing this performance, and then a couple of people turned up. This was a fun idea, but they also knew it wouldn't be easy, because a lot of the other players in GTA are primed for violence. If I could just request that you refrain from killing each other. It was like a real kind of electric feeling, that adrenaline you get in performance. And don't kill the actors either. Since most interactions in the game involve murder. It's a little bit strange to come across a group of folks standing around peacefully rehearsing a Shakespeare play. So, Sam and Mark found that every audition was a risk to their lives. And then obviously the fact that when they started shooting each other and then the
服务器里的人说，嘿，我们在搞这个演出，然后几个人就出现了。这是一个有趣的主意，但他们也知道这并不容易，因为 GTA 中的许多其他玩家都充满了暴力倾向。如果我能请求你们克制一下，不要互相残杀。这有一种真正带电的感觉，那种你在表演中获得的肾上腺素。而且也别杀演员。由于游戏中的大多数互动都涉及谋杀。遇到一群人安安静静地站在那里排练莎士比亚戏剧，感觉有点奇怪。所以，山姆和马克发现，每一次试镜都是对他们生命的冒险。然后很明显，当他们开始互相射击然后
police turn up, again, that just adds to it. It was just like, oh my God, this is alive, this is dangerous, this is like theatrical. Shit, there's the police. Oh, farewell, honest soldier. Who has relieved you? You can't stop our motherfuck. Oh, they got me. Me too. Staging this Grand Theft Auto version of Hamlet became a full-time obsession for Sam,
警察出现时，这又增加了这种感觉。这就像，哦天哪，这是活生生的，这是危险的，这就像戏剧性的。该死，警察来了。哦，再见，诚实的士兵。谁换了你的班？你们阻止不了我们的他妈的。哦，他们抓住我了。我也是。将这个《侠盗猎车手》版本的《哈姆雷特》搬上舞台成了山姆全职的痴迷，
whose wife Piny is a documentary filmmaker. And since she also couldn't practice her craft outside of the house, she decided to make her pandemic project a behind-the-scenes documentary of Sam's pandemic project. Sam and I had never worked together, But it kind of felt like, oh, this is territory that I kind of like and know about. What does a filmmaker in GTA look like? Oh, you can choose.
他的妻子皮妮是一名纪录片导演。由于她也无法在屋外进行创作，她决定将她的疫情项目打造成一部关于山姆疫情项目幕后花絮的纪录片。山姆和我从未合作过，但感觉就像是，哦，这是我有点喜欢并了解的领域。GTA 中的电影制作人是什么样子的？哦，你可以选择。
I would like to look slightly like Tilda Swinton, to be honest. Filming the game is easy. All you have to do is record the screen. But Piny wanted to take what they were doing and make a real film out of it. She wanted it to look cinematic. In GTA, all the players carry guns. but they have the option of switching out their AR-15s for a cell phone, which receives missions and can be used to communicate with other players.
说实话，我希望能长得有点像蒂尔达·斯文顿。拍摄游戏很简单。你所要做的就是录制屏幕。但皮妮想把他们正在做的事情变成一部真正的电影。她希望它看起来有电影感。在 GTA 中，所有玩家都携带枪支。但他们可以选择将 AR-15 换成手机，手机可以接收任务并用于与其他玩家沟通。
This virtual cell phone also has a camera. So Penny decided, instead of carrying a gun, she would switch to the cell phone and film everything with that. You were able to go in and do close-ups with it, and it also made it very still, which was avoiding that swinging-round footage. It's very hectic that you watch on YouTube. And it just meant that I had a sort of cinematic language. I had a variety of different shots.
这个虚拟手机还有一个摄像头。所以皮妮决定，她不再携带枪支，而是换成手机，并用它来拍摄一切。你可以用它进去拍特写，而且它还让画面非常稳定，这就避免了那种晃来晃去的画面。你在 YouTube 上看的那种非常混乱的画面。这意味着我拥有了一种电影语言。我有了各种不同的镜头。
And I just suddenly thought, I do actually think we can do this. Like, it is going to be a film. Over the next year, Sam and Mark staged their production of Hamlet inside GTA. And Penny filmed the whole thing, which became a documentary called Grand Theft Hamlet. It's filmed entirely inside the game. You never see Mark or Sam's real-life bodies. Only their GTA avatars. Grand Theft Hamlet played at South by Southwest in 2024,
我突然觉得，我真的认为我们能做到这一点。这将会是一部电影。在接下来的一年里，山姆和马克在 GTA 内部排演了他们的《哈姆雷特》。而皮妮全程拍摄了这一切，这就变成了一部名为《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》的纪录片。它完全在游戏内部拍摄。你永远看不到马克或山姆现实生活中的身体。只有他们的 GTA 虚拟化身。《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》于 2024 年在西南偏南电影节上映，
where it won Best Documentary Feature. I saw it there, and it blew my mind. It looks like an animated film, but it isn't really. What makes Grand Theft Hamlet special is that it's a documentary filmed entirely in an active virtual world, full of real people's avatars. It's so uncanny to watch, because it has all the surreality and beauty of an animated film,
并在那里赢得了最佳纪录片长片奖。我在那儿看过了，它震撼了我的世界。它看起来像一部动画电影，但实际上又不是。让《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》与众不同的是，它是一部完全在活跃的虚拟世界中拍摄的纪录片，里面充满了真实人们的虚拟化身。观看时有一种超现实的感觉，因为它既有动画电影的超现实感和美感，
but it's also spontaneous and awkward, like a real-life documentary. To me, it felt like an entirely new kind of movie. And to Piny, it felt that way making it. Obviously, I'd never made a film inside a computer game, so it was quite a new challenge. Part of the uncanny feeling of watching Grand Theft Hamlet was that it felt so inevitable. Like, of course, a movie taking place entirely inside a video game works.
但它又像现实生活中的纪录片一样即兴而笨拙。对我来说，这感觉像是一种全新类型的电影。对皮妮来说，在制作它的时候也是这种感觉。很明显，我从未在电脑游戏里制作过电影，所以这是一个相当崭新的挑战。观看《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》所带来的诡异感觉的一部分原因在于，它感觉如此不可避免。就像，完全合乎逻辑，一个完全在电子游戏内部发生的电影是行得通的。
Why hasn't anybody done this before? But it turns out, Grand Theft Hamlet is not the first movie made inside a game. They had stumbled on a whole tradition going back to the 1990s, and it even has a name, Machinima. The word machinima is a portmanteau of machine and cinema. Some people prefer to say machinima. I'm using machinima. Both pronunciations are totally fine. What's important is that it refers to me.
为什么以前没有人这样做过？但事实证明，《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》并不是第一部在游戏内部制作的电影。他们无意中发现了一个可以追溯到 20世纪 90 年代的完整传统，它甚至有一个名字，Machinima（游戏动画电影）。Machinima 这个词是机器（machine）和电影（cinema）的混成词。有些人更喜欢说 Machinima。我用的是 Machinima。这两种发音都完全没问题。重要的是它指的是我。
movies that were filmed using video games, and it was coined back in 1998. Back then, Roger Ebert, the most famous film critic of all time, asked if video game tech would revolutionize the way we make movies. And here's a bulletin. The Sony PlayStation's that will be marketed next year will have about the same computing power as the computers that made Toy Story. Kids will be able to create real-time animation on their own computers. Will that be the beginning of?
使用电子游戏拍摄的电影，这个词是在 1998 年创造的。当时，有史以来最著名的影评人罗杰·埃伯特询问电子游戏技术是否会彻底改变我们制作电影的方式。这里有一个突发新闻。明年将要上市的索尼 PlayStation 将拥有与制作《玩具总动员》的计算机大致相同的计算能力。孩子们将能够在他们自己的计算机上创建实时动画。这会是……的开始吗？
of an artistic renaissance, or maybe will it just make for more point-and-shoot video games? Well, it's a good question. That is a good question, Roger Ebert. The mainstream is just starting to warm up to these kinds of machinimated movies. But 30 years ago, an artistic renaissance was already underway. Because there are some stories that can only be told in the virtual world. One of the pioneers of machinima is the animator Paul Marino. Well before Grand Theft Hamlet and the pandemic, in 1997, Paul was working in film and television, and he'd even won an Emmy.
一场艺术复兴，或者也许它只会造就更多指哪打哪的电子游戏？嗯，这是一个好问题。这真是一个好问题，罗杰·埃伯特。主流社会才刚刚开始接受这种游戏动画电影。但在 30 年前，一场艺术复兴已经在进行中。因为有些故事只能在虚拟世界中讲述。游戏动画电影的先驱之一是动画师保罗·马里诺。早在《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》和疫情之前，即 1997 年，保罗就在电影和电视行业工作，甚至还赢得过艾美奖。
He wanted to make his own work, but he was getting slowed down by the super long wait time to export files, which are called renders. We would send off animation renders that would take days to produce, 48 hours or so, just to have something, you know, to look at. But when Paul Marino was playing the video game, Quake, he realized he could control the animation of the characters instantaneously. And he played with some friends who were also in the world of film, like Frank DeLario. If you're making a live-action TV show, it would be a lot of work to set up a shot, and it would take you maybe a whole day or half a day. We're in Quake, we're pumping out shots.
他想创作自己的作品，但他被导出文件（称为渲染）超长的等待时间给拖慢了。我们会发送动画渲染，需要几天时间才能生成，大约 48 小时左右，仅仅是为了有一些，你知道的，可以看的东西。但当保罗·马里诺在玩电子游戏《雷神之锤》时，他意识到自己可以即时控制角色的动画。他和一些同样在电影界的朋友一起玩，比如弗兰克·德拉里奥。如果你在制作真人电视剧，布置一个镜头会需要很多工作，可能需要一整天或半天的时间。而在《雷神之锤》里，我们正大量产出镜头。
Paul, the animator, and Frank, the live-action filmmaker, were both feeling the same pain, that making movies just took way too long. But in Quake, everything was easier. You push a button, the character moves right away, and you can just film the animation like a regular live-action movie. Paul and Frank loved playing around with it, and when they realized that people were recording their gameplay to brag about how good they were, they saw the potential. With their combined experience in animation and live-action filmmaking, they started making their own movies inside Quake. and this was the birth of the Ill clan. The Ill clan was made up of seven friends in New York City
动画师保罗和真人电影制作人弗兰克都有着同样的痛点，那就是拍电影实在太耗时了。但在《雷神之锤》中，一切都变得更容易了。你按下一个按钮，角色立刻移动，你就可以像拍摄普通真人电影一样拍摄动画。保罗和弗兰克很喜欢摆弄它，当他们意识到人们在录制他们的游戏过程来吹嘘自己有多厉害时，他们看到了潜力。凭借他们在动画和真人电影制作方面的综合经验，他们开始在《雷神之锤》中制作自己的电影。这就是 Ill clan（恶人帮）的诞生。Ill clan 由纽约市的七个朋友组成
who played Quake together, and they all came up with ill names. For example, Paul Marino was Ill Robinson, named after Danger Will Robinson from Lost in Space, and Frank Delario was Ill Bixby, named after Bill Bixby, the actor who played The Incredible Hulk in the 70s. To make movies in Quake, the Ill clan all got together in one room, with their computers connected via cables, and each person would puppeteer a character. But instead of moving around to play the game, they would do it to tell a story. This, of course, was all before the screen recording we know today.
他们一起玩《雷神之锤》，并且都起了很酷的名字。例如，保罗·马里诺叫 Ill Robinson，以《迷失太空》中的 Danger Will Robinson 命名，弗兰克·德拉里奥叫 Ill Bixby，以 70 年代饰演《无敌浩克》的演员比尔·比克西命名。为了在《雷神之锤》中制作电影，Ill clan 的所有人聚在一个房间里，他们的计算机通过电缆连接，每个人都操纵一个虚拟角色。但他们不是为了玩游戏而四处走动，而是为了讲故事。当然，这一切都发生在我们今天所知的屏幕录制之前。
So to film their movies, the Ill clan had to make what's called a demo file, which could be shared online and played back inside another player's copy of course. Quake. And this wasn't the only technical limitation they were dealing with. Whenever you ran out of ammo, they gave you a melee weapon to use, and the melee weapon was an axe. Because they were working inside Quake, the Ill Clan had to figure out a reason for their characters to be carrying around axes. So they turned them in the lumberjacks. How do we justify them walking around axes? So you're like, okay, well, we can at least make them look like lumberjacks if we can't take away their axes. So, their first film, titled Apartment Hunting, was about lumberjacks, looking for an apartment.
因此，为了拍摄他们的电影，Ill clan 必须制作所谓的演示文件，该文件可以在网上分享，并在另一个玩家的《雷神之锤》副版中播放。这并不是他们唯一要处理的技术限制。每当你的弹药耗尽时，他们会给你一件近战武器，而近战武器是一把斧头。因为他们是在《雷神之锤》内部工作的，所以 Ill clan 必须想出一个让他们的角色随身携带斧头的理由。于是他们把角色变成了伐木工。我们如何证明他们拿着斧头到处走是合理的？所以你会想，好吧，如果不能拿走他们的斧头，我们至少能让他们看起来像伐木工。所以，他们的第一部电影名为《寻找公寓》，讲述的是伐木工寻找公寓的故事。
Non-lumberjacks to see the apartment. Not lumberjacks, my eyes. You guys are both carrying axes. All three of you are. The 3D graphics of Quake were impressive for the time, but the characters were still pretty blocky, and there wasn't a lot of details in the faces, so like a theater production, they had to rely on loud performances to get their emotions across. They called, I got it. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. They called apartment hunting a quartoon, like a cartoon but with a cue for Quake. Their work was super inspired by Looney Tunes of the Marks Brothers.
非伐木工看公寓。不是伐木工，我的眼睛啊。你们俩都带着斧头。你们三个都带着。《雷神之锤》的 3D 图形在当时令人印象深刻，但角色仍然相当块状，面部也没有太多细节，所以就像戏剧制作一样，他们不得不依靠夸张的表演来传达他们的情感。他们喊道，我拿到了。我们很好。我们很好。我们很好。他们把《寻找公寓》称为 quartoon，就像卡通（cartoon）但用 Q 开头代表《雷神之锤》（Quake）。他们的作品深受乐一通和马克思兄弟的启发。
It's a lot of silly slapstick comedy. And to film the action, the Ill Klan designated one player as the camera person, whose point of view captured all the action. One of the things about creating a Quake movie was that it also needed to play back in Quake. We didn't have YouTube at the time, so it wasn't like you could just upload a stream file for people to watch. And as a result of that, in order to do an edit, the camera person effectively would need to teleport. Okay, so there are interdimensional gateways and quake that the player can use to fast travel between locations. The Ill clan repurposed them to imitate the effect of having multiple cameras by teleporting the camera person to a different location in order to get a different angle.
有很多愚蠢的打闹喜剧。为了拍摄动作，Ill clan 指定一名玩家担任摄像师，其视角捕捉了所有动作。制作《雷神之锤》电影的一大特点是它也需要在《雷神之锤》中回放。我们当时没有 YouTube，所以并不是说你随便上传一个流媒体文件就能让大家看。因此，为了进行剪辑，摄像师实际上需要进行瞬间移动。好吧，所以在《雷神之锤》中，玩家可以使用超维网关在不同地点之间快速穿梭。Ill clan 重新利用它们来模仿多摄像机的效果，通过将摄像师瞬间传送到不同的地点来获得不同的角度。
For example, an apartment hunting, the two main Lumberjack characters get separated. and the intercuts between them in different rooms. Duke caucus could not have won that election. Well, the problem was he understood the political machine, but wow, nice, cool. This intercut between this very kind of intellectual discussion. But Heidegger and Hegel didn't even know each other. But they understood existence. They understood how it preceded essence.
例如，在《寻找公寓》中，两个主要的伐木工角色分开了。在不同房间里他们之间的交叉剪辑。杜卡基斯不可能赢得那场选举。好吧，问题是他理解政治机器，但是，哇，太棒了，太酷了。这种对这种非常具有知识分子的讨论的交叉剪辑。但海德格尔和黑格尔甚至都不认识对方。但他们理解存在。他们理解存在如何先于本质。
And just this absolute, the most stupid thing we could show on screen. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Hey, Larry! People in the Quake community loved Apartment Hunt. Their demo file became a cult favorite, but Paul had a bigger vision for Machinima. He wanted people who didn't play Quake to be able to watch their movies. And so he started a non-profit called The Academy for Machinima Arts and Sciences, which claimed that Machinima was going to take over Hollywood by speeding up production 30 to 40%.
还有这种绝对的、我们能在屏幕上展示的最蠢的事情。哦，哦，哦，哦。嘿，拉里。《雷神之锤》社区的人们非常喜欢《寻找公寓》。他们的演示文件成为了邪典最爱，但保罗对游戏动画电影有着更大的宏图。他希望不玩《雷神之锤》的人也能看他们的电影。因此，他创办了一个名为“游戏动画艺术与科学学院”的非营利组织，声称游戏动画电影将通过将制作速度提高 30% 到 40% 来接管好莱坞。
Machinima became very popular very quickly, a sitcom-style show. filmed in the game Halo, called Red vs. Blue, was a massive success. It spawned a company called Rooster Teeth. There was also a website called Machinema.com, which was a central hub for viewing Machinima films before YouTube existed. In 2001, Timeout New York wrote a feature about Machinima featuring quotes from Roger Ebert, who said Machinima proved that affordable, accessible animation is on the way. Soon, Machinima started making appearances on television. The Drew Carey show filmed inside The Sims.
游戏动画电影迅速变得非常受欢迎，一部在游戏《光环》中拍摄的情景喜剧风格的节目，名为《红魔大战红蓝军》，取得了巨大成功。它催生了一家名为 Rooster Teeth 的公司。还有一个名为 Machinima.com 的网站，它是 YouTube 存在之前观看游戏动画电影的核心枢纽。2001 年，《纽约超时》杂志发表了一篇关于游戏动画电影的专题报道，其中引用了罗杰·埃伯特的话，他说游戏动画电影证明了负担得起的、无障碍的动画正在路上。很快，游戏动画电影开始出现在电视上。《德鲁·凯里秀》在《模拟人生》内部拍摄。
The Beastie Boys directed a music video in NBA Street 3 for MTV. But perhaps the biggest piece of Machinimated TV came via Comedy Central. This could very well lead to the end of the world of Warcraft. And an episode of South Park called Make Love Not Warcraft, the character's voices were coming out of their avatars in the World of Warcraft video game. This episode actually won an Emmy. The South Park guys needed to make it as Machinima because of the show's super quick production schedule. Here's South Park's Trey Parker talking about that in an audio commentary. It's kind of like directing a live action shoot.
野兽男孩在 MTV 的《NBA街头篮球3》中导演了一部音乐录影带。但也许最大的一部游戏动画电影电视是通过喜剧中心播出的。这很可能会导致《魔兽世界》的终结。在《南方公园》一集名为《制爱，非魔兽》中，角色的声音是从《魔兽世界》电子游戏中的虚拟化身中发出来的。这一集实际上赢得了艾美奖。由于该节目超快的制作进度，《南方公园》的人必须将其制作成游戏动画电影。以下是《南方公园》的特雷·帕克在音频评论中谈到这一点。这有点像导演真人拍摄。
You're just sitting there going, okay, everyone run over here. And they would just all do it within the game. and we'd capture that, having to animate all those individually would have taken forever. With all of this happening, machinema.com became an economic powerhouse, becoming one of YouTube's top five channels, reaching over a billion monthly views. They made a deal with game studios so machinimators could monetize their work. For a time, it seemed like a few lucky creators could make a career from Machinima. While Machinimo's going mainstream, the original artists like Paul Marino were still off on the sidelines, trying to make art with their work and push the medium forward.
你只是坐在那里说，好吧，大家跑过来。然后他们就会在游戏里照做。我们会捕捉下来，如果要把所有这些都单独制作动画将需要永恒的时间。随着这一切的发生，Machinima.com 成为一个经济巨头，成为 YouTube 的前五大频道之一，每月浏览量超过十亿次。他们与游戏工作室达成协议，让游戏动画电影制作人能够将他们的作品变现。有一段时间，似乎一些幸运的创作者可以从游戏动画电影中获得一份事业。当游戏动画电影走向主流时，像保罗·马里诺这样的原初艺术家仍然被晾在一边，试图用他们的作品创作艺术并推动媒介向前发展。
All these television shows got permission from the people who made the games to broadcast their work. But a lot of independent creators, like Paul, couldn't make real money off of Machinema. We were in this kind of punk rock phase where we're like, yeah, we'd do all this stuff with this. game technology and fuck all the legal stuff around it. But at the same time, you know, we want to be looked at as people that are serious about our craft. As Machinima started to find audiences and commercial success, the Ill clan were setting out to prove that Machinima should be taken seriously as an art form.
所有这些电视节目都获得了制作游戏的授权来广播他们的作品。但许多独立创作者，比如保罗，无法从游戏动画电影中赚到真正的钱。我们当时处于这种朋克摇滚阶段，我们觉得，是的，我们要用这种游戏技术做所有这些事情，去他妈的周围所有法律问题。但与此同时，你知道，我们希望被视为对我们的手艺严肃对待的人。当游戏动画电影开始找到受众和商业成功时，Ill clan 正着手证明游戏动画电影应该作为一种艺术形式受到严肃对待。
For the sequel to Apartment Hutton, Paul Marino hacked into Quake and imported his own custom 3D models, so they weren't using any of the game. IP, like characters or locations, just the underlying software that makes the game run in real time. The Ill Klan were winning a bunch of awards at film festivals around the world. But the Ill Klan's next big innovation is what took Machinima to the next level. Everything they had made up until this point was basically an animated film that happens to have been made inside a video game. In 2004, they were invited to the Florida Film Festival for their first. first ever live performance.
对于《寻找公寓》的续集，保罗·马里诺黑进了《雷神之锤》并导入了他自己的自定义 3D 模型，这样他们就没有使用任何游戏的知识产权，比如角色或地点，只使用了使游戏实时运行的底层软件。Ill clan 在世界各地的电影节上赢得了许多奖项。但 Ill clan 的下一个重大创新是将游戏动画电影提升到一个新水平的关键。在此之前他们制作的所有东西基本上都是碰巧在电子游戏内部制作的动画电影。2004 年，他们受邀参加佛罗里达电影节，进行了他们的第一次。有史以来第一次现场表演。
The Ilklan is about to take the process one step further. They're now ready to produce a Machinima film in front of a live audience. Frank Delario from Ilklan told me that the Florida Film Festival had heard about how they could render animation in real time. What they heard was, oh, they do live animation. So they contact us like, hey, you want to come down at Florida Film Festival and do live animation. Ciao, Benavinovino, and welcome to Common Sense of Cooking with Cook Carl, the show where you can learn to cook just like Cook Carl.
Ill clan 即将把这个过程向前推进一步。他们现在准备在现场观众面前制作一部游戏动画电影。来自 Ill clan 的弗兰克·德拉里奥告诉我，佛罗里达电影节听说他们如何能够实时渲染动画。他们听到的是，哦，他们在做现场动画。所以他们联系我们，嘿，你想来佛罗里达电影节做现场动画吗。乔，贝纳维诺维诺，欢迎来到大厨卡尔的烹饪常识，在这里你可以学到像大厨卡尔一样做饭。
Thanks to Paul's custom 3D models, the digital puppeteers could now control not only the mouths of the characters to lip-sing to what they were saying, but also subtle facial expressions, like raising an eyebrow, and they could do it live. They made a film in real time called Common Sense Cooking with Carl the Cook. I was thinking maybe to make this into Lenny Lumberjack's cooking show. What do you think?
多亏了保罗的自定义 3D 模型，数字木偶师现在不仅可以控制角色的嘴唇来配合他们所说的话进行对口型，还可以控制微妙的面部表情，比如挑起眉毛，而且他们可以现场直播。他们实时制作了一部名为《与厨师卡尔一起学烹饪常识》的电影。我在想也许可以把这个做成林尼伐木工的烹饪节目。你觉得呢？
I don't think it's a good idea. Yeah, they like the idea. Oh, Carl, it'll be fine. You're a human interest. Let's go on the back. Sorry, Carl, you're out. Afterwards, people were kind of like, whoa, like, they were, like, freaking out. It's understandable that people were freaking out.
我觉得这不是个好主意。是的，他们喜欢这个主意。哦，卡尔，没事的。你是一个具有人性化兴趣的人。我们去后面吧。对不起，卡尔，你出局了。事后，人们有点像，哇，就像，他们吓坏了。人们吓坏是可以理解的。
Nobody had ever seen anything like live animation. Characters, up on a movie screen, responding to the audience in real time. It was a huge hit, and they took the show on. the road, performing live at Stanford and even the Lincoln Center. The Il Klan were the first people to really take advantage of the real-time aspect of Machinima to do something completely unique, beyond simply making animation faster. The very next year, 2005, Halo 2 dropped. It included a voice chat for players to talk with each other, both friends and strangers. This was revolution from a cinema. No one had ever filmed a movie and a functioning, active, virtual world,
从来没有人见过像现场动画这样的东西。大屏幕上的角色，实时对观众做出反应。这是一个巨大的轰动，他们带着这个节目上路了。在巡回演出中，在斯坦福甚至林肯中心进行现场表演。Ill clan 是第一批真正利用游戏动画电影的实时特性来做一些完全独特的事情的人，超越了单纯地让动画制作得更快。紧接着的第二年，即 2005 年，推出《光环 2》。它包含了一个语音聊天功能，供玩家彼此交谈，无论是朋友还是陌生人。这对于电影制作来说是一场革命。从来没有人拍摄过一部电影在一个功能齐全、活跃的虚拟世界里，
full of people from around our terrestrial world. This opened up lots of new possibilities. Like a live talk show. Live from New Mambasa in the unpredictable multiplayer universe, this Spartan life. Six months after Halo 2 dropped, a musician named Chris Burke came out. with the first episode of This Spartan Life. A late-night talk show with monologues, sketches, and a host trying to hold it all together while strangers killed the people he was interviewing. Hey, guys, no burning the guests alive, please.
里面充满了来自我们陆地世界各地的人们。这开启了许多新的可能性。就像现场脱口秀一样。从不可预测的多人游戏宇宙中的新蒙巴萨现场直播，这个斯巴达生命。在《光环 2》发布六个月后，一位名叫克里斯·伯克的音乐人推出了。推出了《这个斯巴达生命》的第一集。一档深夜脱口秀节目，有独白、小品，还有一个主持人在陌生人杀死他正在采访的人的同时，试图把场面维持下去。嘿，伙计们，请不要把客人活活烧死。
What made this Spartan life so special is that it's not just an animated talk show. The host and the guest are surrounded by real people who are playing the game. There's so many outtakes I have of me just like yelling at the people in the game. You know, like, don't kill the guest. We're shooting a bad choice of work. We're recording an interview. The show is largely an investigation into what it means to exist as a human in one of these virtual worlds. And no guest spoke better to the magic of being an artist in the online game space than Malcolm McLaren,
《这个斯巴达生命》如此特别的原因在于，它不仅仅是一个动画脱口秀节目。主持人和嘉宾被玩游戏的真实人物包围着。我有很多未采用的片段，都是我对着游戏里的人大喊大叫。你知道，比如，别杀嘉宾。我们在拍摄一个糟糕的工作选择。我们在录制采访。这个节目在很大程度上是对作为一个人类存在于这些虚拟世界之一意味着什么的探索。没有哪个嘉宾比马尔科姆·麦克拉伦更能体现作为在线游戏空间艺术家的魔力，
legendary fashion designer and manager of the sex pistols. The virtual world becomes a more comfortable world, a world where that, outlaw spirit can exist in a world where you can absolutely continue to have magnificent failures, a world where you can in truth become an artist again. This is the real true story of rock and roll. It was not about anything other than how to live your life as a gangster in sartorial splendor and turning the world into a place where normality would never return again. This new direction for Machinima led to many imitators that got a lot of media attention and travel to film festivals around the world.
传奇时装设计师兼性手枪乐队经纪人。虚拟世界变成了一个更舒适的世界，一个那种无法无天的精神可以存在的世界，一个你可以绝对继续遭遇壮丽失败的世界，一个你可以真正再次成为艺术家的世界。这就是摇滚乐的真实故事。它与如何作为一名穿着考究的匪徒过着你的生活无关，也与将世界变成一个常态将永远不会再返回的地方无关。游戏动画电影的这种新方向引来了许多模仿者，他们获得了大量媒体关注并前往世界各地的电影节。
The French democracy, Molotov Alva and his search for the creator, the list goes on. But the golden age of Machinima only lasted a few years. First, Machinema.com took a turn for the worse. According to Chris Burke, a lot of young Machinima creators signed bad, contracts with them. Within a few years, they got a little bit older and realized what it happened, and they started being very vocal about it on the internet, and machinema.com got a really bad name. Eventually, machinima.com realized that they didn't even need machinimators.
《法国民主》、《莫洛托夫·阿尔瓦和他在寻找创作者》，名单不胜枚举。但游戏动画电影的黄金时代只持续了几年。首先，Machinima.com 转向了更糟糕的方向。据克里斯·伯克说，许多年轻的游戏动画电影创作者与他们签了糟糕的合同。几年之内，他们长大了一点，意识到发生了什么，他们开始在互联网上直言不讳地表达这一点，Machinima.com 获得了一个非常糟糕的名声。最终，Machinima.com 意识到他们甚至不需要游戏动画电影制作人。
You could get even more views on a video of someone just playing a game and talking. No edits, no scripts, no fancy filmmaking. And popular shows like Red versus Blue also stopped making Machinima, and Switch. switched to traditional animation. Machinima.com and Rooster Teeth both ended up getting bought out and shut down by AT&T, and their entire archives were erased. Today, if you go to machinema.com, you're forwarded to Warner Bros. Discovery's website. An independent machinimators felt they weren't being taken seriously as artists either. Paul Marino of the Ilklan was invited to an animation festival in Canada.
你甚至可以从某人玩游戏和聊天的视频中获得更多浏览量。没有剪辑，没有剧本，没有华丽的电影制作。像《红魔大战红蓝军》这样受欢迎的节目也停止制作游戏动画电影，并转向了。转向了传统动画。Machinima.com 和 Rooster Teeth 最终都被 AT&T 收购并关停，它们的整个档案都被抹去了。今天，如果你去 Machinima.com，你会被转发到华纳兄弟探索公司的网站。而独立的戏谑动画制作人也觉得他们作为艺术家没有被认真对待。Ill clan 的保罗·马里诺受邀参加了加拿大的一场动画节。
that had an award category specifically for Machinima. But they decided not to give an award to any of the nominees. Right at that point, I stood up and walked out, and all the other Machineman filmmakers followed me. A lot of other Machinima creators followed Paul, out of the Machinima game, and into the video game. Paul went to work on video games, making what are called cinematics or cutscenes,
该电影节有一个专门针对游戏动画电影的奖项类别。但他们决定不将奖项颁给任何提名者。就在那个时候，我站起来走了出去，所有其他的游戏动画电影制作人也跟着我走了。许多其他的游戏动画电影制作人跟随保罗，退出了游戏动画电影圈，进入了电子游戏行业。保罗去从事电子游戏工作，制作被称为“过场动画”或“剧情动画”的内容，
the parts of the game that just play like a movie to move the story along. Frank Delario of the Ill clan held on for a long time. He made an episode of CSI, New York, where Gary Sinise finds a killer through Second Life. Second Life? It's a metaverse, an online social network inside a virtual world. And a Super Bowl commercial for the sitcom Two and a Half Men, using The Sims. Charlie, the virtual world is amazing. I can be anything or go anywhere I want.
即游戏中像电影一样播放以推动剧情发展的片段。Ill clan 的弗兰克·德拉里奥坚持了很长时间。他制作了一集《CSI：纽约》，其中加里·西尼斯通过《第二人生》找到了一名杀手。《第二人生》？这是一个元宇宙，一个虚拟世界内部的在线社交网络。还有一个情景喜剧《好汉两个半》的超级碗广告，使用的是《模拟人生》。查理，虚拟世界太棒了。我可以成为任何人或去我想去的任何地方。
Charlie, why aren't you changing? Alan, I'm single, rich, and I live at the beach. I'm okay with reality. But eventually, the novelty wore off, and paying work, making machinima, disappeared completely. We stopped in 2010, officially, and then we went into just traditional video from that point. Yeah.
查理，你为什么不改变？艾伦，我是单身汉，很有钱，而且我住在海滩上。我对现实很满意。但最终，新鲜感消失了，制作游戏动画电影的有偿工作完全消失了。我们在 2010 年正式停止了，然后从那时起我们就只从事传统的视频制作。是的。
And did you miss, you know, to make you know, making movies on the video games? At the time, I don't think I did. But at one point, I'm working at an ad agency here, and it was in San Francisco. I was a project manager, and we're doing, you know, mobile websites and things like that. You know, for AT&T, for big clients and stuff like that. And at one point, I show one of the videos that we did. And it was a VP, and she goes, oh, my God, well, what's you doing here?
你有没有怀念过，你知道的，在电子游戏上制作电影？当时，我想我没有。但有一次，我在这里的一家广告公司工作，在旧金山。我是一名项目经理，我们当时在做，你知道的，移动网站之类的事情。你知道，为 AT&T 等大客户服务。有一次，我展示了我们制作的一个视频。那是一位副总裁，她说，哦，天哪，好吧，你在这里做什么？
I was like, oh, my God, you know, you felt terrible because, I mean, we were in New York Times, We performed live at Lincoln Center and all that. But, and I imagine, like a band, you have your period of time, and then after you're not the bell of the ball anymore, and then what? All of this Machinima history went away and was forgotten. And for a full decade, the 2010s, not much happened. But now, finally, I feel like the dream of Machinima taking over the cinema? is coming true. A lot of Hollywood movies use virtual production,
我当时想，哦，天哪，你知道的，你感觉很糟糕，因为，我的意思是，我们曾登上《纽约时报》，我们在林肯中心进行了现场表演等等。但是，我想象着，就像一支乐队，你有你的时期，然后之后你不再是舞会上最受欢迎的人了，然后呢？所有这些游戏动画电影的历史都消逝了，被遗忘了。在整整十年里，即 2010 年代，没有发生太多事情。但现在，终于，我觉得游戏动画电影接管电影的梦想？正在成真。许多好莱坞电影使用虚拟制作，
a technique in which real-time video game engines, like Unreal, are used to put actors in virtual environments. This is what they use on a little movie series called Avatar and the Star Wars TV show The Mandalorian. Virtual production isn't exactly machinima, but it wouldn't exist without machinema. And Machinima proper is coming back, too. And it's not just Grand Theft Hamlet.
这是一种技术，其中实时游戏引擎（如虚幻引擎）被用来将演员置于虚拟环境中。这就是他们在一部名为《阿凡达》的小电影系列和星际大战电视剧《曼达洛人》中使用的技术。虚拟制作并不完全是游戏动画电影，但如果没有游戏动画电影，它就不会存在。而且真正的游戏动画电影也正在回归。而且不仅仅是《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》。
There's a whole new wave of documentary Machinima. Nitz Island, another documentary filmed inside an online video game, has won lots of awards at film festivals. It was even nominated for Best Feature at the same film festival that Paul Marino walked out of. And a film called The Remarkable Life of Ibelin won Best Documentary at Sundance and was shortlisted for the best documentary Oscar. It uses Machinima to recreate the virtual life of Mott's Steen, a teenager with muscular dystrophy,
涌现出了一股全新的纪录片游戏动画电影浪潮。《尼茨岛》，另一部在在线电子游戏内部拍摄的纪录片，在各大电影节上赢得了许多奖项。它甚至在保罗·马里诺退场的同一个电影节上被提名最佳长片。一部名为《伊贝尔令人瞩目的生活》的电影在圣丹斯电影节上赢得了最佳纪录片奖，并入围了奥斯卡最佳纪录片短名单。它利用游戏动画电影重现了患有肌营养不良症的少年莫茨·斯蒂恩的虚拟生活，
who lived a vivid life online in the world of Warcraft. In there, my chains are broken, and I can be whoever I want to be. We had the whole, let's go on a date together, and he would give the flowers. It was just a virtual kiss. But boy, I could almost feel it. To me, this doesn't feel like a flash in the pan.
他在《魔兽世界》的世界里过着生动的在线生活。在那里，我的枷锁断裂了，我可以成为我想成为的任何人。我们经历了整整一套，让我们一起去约会，他会送花。这只是一个虚拟的吻。但是天哪，我几乎能感觉到它。对我来说，这感觉不像是昙花一现。
Machinima is taking the documentary film world by Storm. Remarkable Life of Ibelin has been a huge hit on Netflix, and Grand Theft Hamlet became the first machinima ever to be released in movie theaters earlier this year. I'm kind of surprised that we are weirdly like the first machinima film to be distributed in a cinema. You know, I think there'll be more stuff like this. Penny and the rest of the Grand Theft Hamlet team loved working inside a video game,
游戏动画电影正以风暴般的速度席卷纪录片电影界。《伊贝尔令人瞩目的生活》在 Netflix 上大获成功，《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》成为了今年早些时候第一部在电影院上映的游戏动画电影。我有点惊讶，我们竟然离奇地成为了第一部在电影院发行的游戏动画电影。你知道，我认为会有更多这样的东西。皮妮和《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》团队的其他成员很喜欢在电子游戏内部工作，
and the things that it unlocked for them as no-budget indie filmmakers making a movie in their bedroom. For example, they got to film on a blimp for free, which is nice. Also, Hamlet, it's a ghost story, but they didn't have to design any crazy special effects. They could just turn the character into a ghost using passive mode. Impartive mode in the game, you're transparent. You're kind of see-through, and people can literally walk through you. Pini was also intrigued by the limitations of filming in GTA-5, because when you're making a movie inside a game,
以及它作为零预算独立电影制作人在卧室里拍电影时为他们解锁的东西。例如，他们可以免费乘坐飞艇拍摄，这很不错。此外，《哈姆雷特》是一个鬼故事，但他们不需要设计任何疯狂的特效。他们只需使用被动模式就可以把角色变成幽灵。在游戏中的被动模式下，你是透明的。你有点半透明，人们实际上可以从你身体穿过去。皮妮也对在 GTA-5 中拍摄的局限性很感兴趣，因为当你在游戏内部制作电影时，
you have to follow some rules. There was actually some super really interesting things, which I wish I'd put more into the film about weird workarounds that they had to do. The closet scene, obviously, Polonius has to get murdered by Hamlet or accidentally, but you can't kill people inside. Yes. You cannot be killed in an indoor space in GTA5.
你必须遵守一些规则。实际上有一些超级有趣的事情，我希望我在电影中加入更多关于他们不得不做的奇怪变通方法的细节。衣柜那场戏，很明显，波洛涅斯必须被哈姆雷特杀死或意外杀死，但你不能在室内杀人。是的。你不能在 GTA5 的室内空间被杀死。
So we had to find somewhere where there was something that could conceivably be a closet, but it had me outside. So we used the grotto in the Playbill Mansion. Yeah, yeah. So it was tricky. Despite the challenges, Pini sees a lot of benefits to working in Machinima as a documentarian.
所以我们必须找一个地方，那里有某种可以想象成衣柜的东西，但它在室外。所以我们使用了花花公子大厦里的石窟。是的，是的。所以这很棘手。尽管面临挑战，皮妮作为一名纪录片制作人，认为在游戏动画电影中工作有很多好处。
even now that the pandemic's over. In fact, she's now working on an expanded, immersive version of their Grand Theft Hamlet performance called Be the Players Ready. So much of making a documentary is about access. And for Penny, one of the most amazing things about filming inside an online video game, is that you can meet and talk with people all around the world without leaving your apartment. The magic of Machinima is in how it can connect people who would have, never, ever been in the same place otherwise.
即使现在疫情已经结束。事实上，她现在正在致力于他们的《侠盗猎车手哈姆雷特》演出的一个扩展的、沉浸式的版本，名为《玩家准备好了吗》。制作纪录片很大程度上在于获取权限。对皮妮来说，在在线电子游戏内部拍摄最奇妙的事情之一就是，你无需离开公寓就可以结识并与世界各地的人交谈。游戏动画电影的魅力在于它能够连接那些原本永远、永远不可能身处同一地点的人。
I think that it just gives you access and opportunity to find all these amazing characters. I think that's something that is pretty unique. I mean, I don't know of another environment that offers that. There's something inherently exciting about that game space. And, like, I think the filmmakers, worth their soul, are always attracted to making films that reflect the world we live in, right? And increasingly, people are living in game spaces for many hours a day. And it would be very odd if we didn't start turning our attention to those narratives and to those relationships and to those communities.
我认为这只是赋予了你接触和寻找所有这些神奇角色的途径与机会。我认为这相当独特。我的意思是，我不知道还有什么其他环境能提供这种体验。那个游戏空间本身就有一种令人兴奋的特质。而且，我认为，有灵魂的电影制作人总是倾向于拍摄反映我们所处世界的电影，对吧？而且越来越多的人每天要在游戏空间里生活好几个小时。如果我们不开始把注意力转向这些叙事、这些关系和这些社区，那将是非常奇怪的。
And so it was kind of inevitable in a way. Pimmie's not done making art with video games. She learned while making Grand Theft Hamlet, there are things you can only film inside a game. We have more with Andrew Calloway after this. Ben Brock Johnson. Roman Mars. We're back with Andrew Calloway. Hey, Andrew.
所以这在某种程度上是不可避免的。Pimmie 并没有停止用电子游戏创作艺术。她在制作《侠盗哈姆雷特》时了解到，有些事情只能在游戏里拍摄。稍后我们将为您带来更多关于安德鲁·卡洛维的采访。本·布罗克·约翰逊。罗曼·马尔斯。我们和安德鲁·卡洛维回来了。嘿，安德鲁。
Hey, Roman. Hey, Ben. So I know there are a lot of recent developments in the world of Machinima that we couldn't get to in your story. And you want to talk about some of them. Yeah, right. So, you know, there's this big renaissance in Machinema right now. You remember in the story I talked about rooster teeth? They were the company that made red versus blue.
嘿，罗曼。嘿，本。我知道在 machinima（游戏动画）世界里有很多最近的发展，我们在你的故事里没能讲完。你想谈谈其中一些。是的，没错。所以，你知道的，现在 machinima 正经历着一场巨大的文艺复兴。你还记得我在故事里提到的 Rooster Teeth 吗？他们就是制作《红蓝生死斗》的那家公司。
Yes. Red versus Blue was my first introduction to all of this. It was a big deal when it came out when I was aware of it. Well, so Rooster Teeth, the company that made Red versus Blue, were bought out in 2014. And AT&T shut down their archives last year. But now one of the original creators just bought back the company name and has like revived the domain and the archives. And presumably they're planning on bringing back Red versus Blue, one of the most popular machinima series of all time. But also, there's a lot of new people getting into it.
是的。《红蓝生死斗》是我接触这一切的最初契机。它刚出来我注意到它的时候，引起了很大的轰动。那么，制作《红蓝生死斗》的 Rooster Teeth 公司在 2014 年被收购了。而 AT&T 在去年关闭了他们的档案库。但现在，其中一位创始人刚刚买回了公司名称，并复活了域名和档案库。据推测，他们正计划带回有史以来最受欢迎的 machinima 系列之一《红蓝生死斗》。不仅如此，还有很多新的人才涌入这个领域。
to the world of the Mishinawa. Like, do you know the filmmaker Harmony Corrin? Yes. Yeah. I saw kids when it came out. And, yeah, I will never forget seeing kids. And Spring Breakers as well has done a lot of crazy stuff. But now he's interested in video game technology.
进入 machinima 的世界。比如，你知道电影制作人哈armony Korine 吗？知道。是的。他拍的《孩子们》上映时我就看了。而且，是的，我看《孩子们》的场景我永远不会忘。《春假》也做过很多疯狂的事情。但现在他对电子游戏技术感兴趣了。
And he's set up a studio called Edge Lord, but, you know, it's missing some vowels in there. Of course it's called Edge Lord. Of course it's called Edge Lord. And, you know, his latest film Baby Invasion played the Venice Film Festival. and he's using Machinima technology to be able to kind of remix it live as a kind of DJVJ set, which is cool. But for me, the best shot of Machinima entering mass culture is a thing called Skibbitty Toilet. Have you all, you've all heard of this, I assume. I of course know what Skibbitty Toilet is in passing, certainly, although I'm not Generation Alpha.
他成立了一个名为 Edge Lord 的工作室，不过，你知道的，里面少了一些元音字母。它当然叫 Edge Lord。当然叫 Edge Lord。而且，你知道的，他的最新电影《宝贝入侵》在威尼斯电影节上映了。他正在使用 machinima 技术，将其作为一种 DJVJ 表演现场混音，这很酷。但对我来说，machinima 进入大众文化最好的代表是一个叫做“斯基比蒂厕所”（Skibidi Toilet）的东西。你们大概都听说过这个吧。我当然顺便知道什么是斯基比蒂厕所，虽然我不是 Alpha 一代。
Well, it's a YouTube series, and yes, it went super viral. It was so popular at its height It was getting over 3 billion monthly views Which is like more successful than any TV show ever Wow But what most people don't know about it is that it's Machinima Huh, huh, that's so cool So could you explain to us a little bit
好吧，这是一个 YouTube 系列视频，是的，它超级火爆。在它最火的时候，它有多受欢迎？它每月的观看量超过 30 亿次，这比以往任何电视节目都要成功。哇。但大多数人不知道的是，它是 machinima。哈，哈，太酷了。那么你能给我们简单解释一下
What Skibbitty Toilet is all about? Sure, but I actually talked to a YouTuber named Matt Pat Who created the very popular channel game theory And I think he can explain it a little bit better than me It is an epic transformers like battle between a faction of camera headed people versus a faction of
斯基比蒂厕所到底讲的是什么吗？当然，不过我其实采访过一个名叫 MatPat 的 YouTuber，他创建了非常受欢迎的频道 Game Theory。我想他能比我解释得更好。这是一场史诗般的、类似《变形金刚》的战斗，一方是摄像头脑袋的人，另一方是
toilets with heads coming out of them. Okay. Yeah. Of course. Of course. Okay, so let me repeat this back so that I make sure I got it right. There are toilets with human heads. Yes. And then there are other creatures with human bodies but camera heads and they are
长着人头从里面探出来的马桶。好的。是的。当然。当然。好吧，让我重复一遍，以便确保我没理解错。有长着人头的马桶。是的。然后还有其他生物，有着人类的身体，但脑袋是摄像头，他们在
fighting in a battle. Transformers like battle, Roman. Transformers like battle. That's right. So how do a camera heads and toilet head people, how do, how do they fight? So it really starts with the camera headed people, just flushing the human heads down the toilet. And then, you know, the toilets fight back with lasers out of their eyes that they shoot at people. And next thing you know, entire cities are getting decimated. The scale gets bigger and bigger and bigger. Because
进行战斗。像《变形金刚》一样的战斗，罗曼。像《变形金刚》一样的战斗。没错。那么，摄像头人和马桶头人，他们是如何战斗的呢？其实一开始是摄像头人把人类的脑袋冲进马桶里。然后，你知道的，马桶会用眼睛射出的激光进行反击。接下来，你会发现整个城市都被毁了。规模变得越来越大，因为
eventually, the skibbitty toilets and the camera head people have to join forces to fight a new enemy called Astro Toilets, which are enormous, and they fly around and they have lots of heavy machinery attached to them and like spinning claws and are very intense. And I know that this all sounds pretty ridiculous, but to me, I think it sounds perfectly normal. But go on. A lot of people would call it brain rot or something like that. Like it's just a random collection of stupid. scatological humor.
最终，斯基比蒂厕所和摄像头人不得不联手对抗一个叫做“阿斯特罗马桶”（Astro Toilets）的新敌人。这些马桶体型巨大，四处飞翔，身上挂满了重型机械，比如旋转的爪子，非常凶猛。我知道这听起来很荒谬，但对我来说，我觉得这完全正常。不过请继续。很多人会称之为“大脑腐蚀”或者类似的东西。觉得它只是一堆无厘头的、粪便幽默的随机组合。
But I think the filmmaking is actually pretty sophisticated. For the first, like, 50 episodes, each scene is like a unbroken oneer. So there's very sophisticated blocking happening in all of these fight scenes that must have been very, very hard to make and design. But it can also be viewed as a piece of media criticism. And Matt Pat says that it can be viewed as an allegory for our media landscape.
但我认为电影制作其实相当成熟。在前 50 集左右，每个场景都像是一个一镜到底的长镜头。所以在所有这些战斗场景中都有非常成熟的场面调度，制作和设计一定非常非常难。但它也可以被视为一件媒体批评作品。MatPat 说，它可以被看作是我们媒体格局的一种寓言。
If you look at how the toilets and the cameras are depicted throughout these 77 episodes, you can tell a meta-narrative about YouTube versus traditional media or digital creators versus traditional creators, right? The toilets, you know, they are these creatures of meme-dom. You know, they're made out of machinima. And then contrast that with the camera people who are high-calibre production equipment,
如果你看看马桶和摄像头在这 77 集中的描绘，你就可以讲述一个关于 YouTube 对决传统媒体，或者数字创作者对决传统创作者的元叙事，对吧？马桶，你知道的，它们是梗文化的产物。你知道，它们是由 machinima 制成的。然后将之与高水准制作设备的摄像头人形成对比，
movie cameras, high-end audio equipment. They attack using the THX sound effect. They're like, blah to test out movie theater sound systems, right? They're attacking with the medium of traditional old school entertainment, like higher-end, classier stuff. Both sides are represented from a different form of music. On one side, you have the toilets that are represented by this kind of mish-mash of songs fused together to create this earworm.
电影摄像机、高端音频设备。他们使用 THX 音效进行攻击。他们就像是，用“嗙”的一声来测试电影院音响系统，对吧？他们用传统老派娱乐媒介进行攻击，比如更高端、更高档的东西。双方代表了不同形式的音乐。一方面，你拥有由这种拼凑在一起、形成洗脑神曲的音乐代表的马桶。
Contrast that with the alliance, the camera-headed people, who use, everybody wants to rule the world by Tears for Fears. Classic like 1980s nostalgia, right? So again, you have this battle between new media, new music, versus old school stuff. I get it. I get it. What about you, Roman? I'm catching on to it. This sounds pretty good and more sophisticated than I was maybe first thought in the very beginning.
相比之下，由摄像头人组成的联盟则使用了 Tears for Fears 的《Everybody Wants to Rule the World》。经典如 20世纪 80 年代的怀旧金曲，对吧？所以再次说明，你看到了新媒体、新音乐与老派事物之间的战斗。我明白了。我明白了。你呢，罗曼？我逐渐理解了。这听起来挺不错的，比我一开始想象的要成熟得多。
But I guess it doesn't explain to me what the Astro Toilets are all about. What is their theme song or what is their agenda? Great question. I asked Matt Pat about this and I thought his theory was pretty interesting. Oh, man, I don't have a whole lot of evidence to support it. It's still early in the Astro Toilet lore. When I look at just broad strokes of what the story has become, you have YouTube, the digital content, has had to join forces with traditional media through the camera heads. and what's the new existential threat for both of these worlds?
但这似乎还是没有向我解释什么是阿斯特罗马桶。它们的主题曲是什么，或者它们的目的是什么？好问题。我问过 MatPat 这个，我觉得他的理论挺有意思的。天哪，我没有太多证据来支持它。阿斯特罗马桶的背景故事还处于早期阶段。当我看到这个故事发展的大致方向时，你会发现 YouTube，这种数字内容，不得不通过摄像头人与传统媒体联手。而这两个世界共同面临的新的存在主义威胁是什么？
It's AI. It's the computer-generated stuff. So they need to work together to take down this big existential threat, Astro Toilet, AI. Yeah, and you know, one of the things that I love personally thinking about Machinima is that the creator of Cibody Toilet is a 25-year-old guy from the country of Georgia. And now he has created one of the most successful pieces of IP introduced in the past decade. And so it feels like Machinima has had this democratizing effect that people have been talking about, you know, back in the 90s. You know, when you put it that way, I mean, I know it was kind of dismissive of skibbitty toilet in the beginning. I mean, like, you know, I'm only human.
是 AI。是计算机生成的东西。所以他们需要齐心协力击败这个巨大的存在主义威胁——阿斯特罗马桶，也就是 AI。是的，你知道，我个人非常喜欢 machinima 的一点是，《斯基比蒂厕所》的创作者是一个来自格鲁吉亚共和国的 25 岁小伙子。现在他创造了过去十年中引入的最成功的 IP 之一。所以这感觉 machinima 带来了人们在 90 年代一直在谈论的那种民主化效应。你这么说的话，我的意思是，我知道我一开始对斯基比蒂厕所有点不屑一顾。我的意思是，你知道的，我只是个凡人。
But when you talk about this 25-year-old guy from Georgia making this like hugely popular, it speaks to so many people with, you know, tools that you can purchase online and do it, is that is kind of amazing. I mean, I was amazed by zines and punk rock. It's the same principle to me. I kind of love it. And if new generations of people are not making art that offends and confounds older people, then they're not trying art enough. That's what art should be about being confusing to me. So I actually love it. You know, and you can watch five or six episodes and about a minute or two because most of them are under 10 seconds.
但当你谈到这个来自格鲁吉亚的 25 岁小伙子制作了这个极其受欢迎的作品，它用你可以在网上买到并亲自动手操作的工具，引起了如此多人的共鸣，这确实有点神奇。我的意思是，我曾对zine（地下刊物）和朋克摇滚感到惊叹。对我来说，这是同一个道理。我有点爱上它了。如果新一代人没有创作出冒犯和困惑老一辈人的艺术，那他们对艺术的尝试还不够。艺术就应该让人感到困惑。所以我其实很喜欢它。你知道的，你可以在一两分钟内看完五六集，因为大多数都不到 10 秒钟。
Ten seconds? Yeah, real quick. Oh, yeah. Well, that earns the name Brain Rod. If the narrative goes 10 seconds long, oh my goodness. You know, a pair of baby shoes never worn. You can do it, Roman. I believe it.
十秒钟？对，真的很快。哦，是的。好吧，这真不愧叫“大脑腐蚀”。如果叙事只有 10 秒长，哦天哪。你知道的，一双从未穿过的婴儿鞋。你能做到的，罗曼。我相信你。
That's true. Thank you, Andrew. Thanks a lot, Andrew. Thanks, guys. Now, Roman, before we end this episode, I have a question for you. Shoot. You're our hero. You're on a big, big quest.
确实如此。谢谢你，安德鲁。非常感谢，安德鲁。谢谢你们，伙计们。现在，罗曼，在我们结束这期节目之前，我有个问题问你。请讲。你是我们的英雄。你正在进行一次盛大、盛大的探险。
And as you're traveling along the open. open road, the dangerous open road, your journey is interrupted by a fellow traveler who needs your help. If you help them, you're veering off from your main quest. Your interruption might lead you to a place where there be dragons, but also maybe where there be treasure, which could help you in your larger quest. Roman Mars, the hero of our story, would you take this side quest? I always take a side quest. I always take a side quest because the big game is like hard to complete. And the side quest is so satisfied. It's just like, it's like a thing on your to-do list that you could knock off first thing in the day, like brush your teeth or something.
当你在开阔的道路上旅行时，危险的开阔道路，你的旅程被一个需要你帮助的同伴打断了。如果你帮助了他们，你就偏离了你的主线任务。你的插曲可能会把你带到一个有龙出没的地方，但也可能是一个有宝藏的地方，这可能会对你更大的任务有所帮助。罗曼·马尔斯，我们故事的英雄，你会接受这个支线任务吗？我总是接受支线任务。我总是接受支线任务，因为主线游戏很难通关。而支线任务太令人满足了。它就像你待办事项清单上可以在一天开始时最先划掉的事情，就像刷牙什么的。
You're always be sidequesting a t-shirt is in the mail. So look out for that. And Roman Mars, fellow traveler and adventurer and sidequester, I have good news for you. We have put together a couple of special side quest episodes for Hidden Levels listeners. And your mission, should you choose to accept it, is to find these episodes on the endless thread feed and listen to them. The first one is out today. It comes to us from producer Frannie Monaghan. Hey, Franny.
你一直在做支线任务，一件T恤正在邮寄中。所以请留意。罗曼·马尔斯，同伴、冒险家和支线任务者，我有个好消息要告诉你。我们为“Hidden Levels”的听众准备了几个特殊的支线任务剧集。你的任务，如果你选择接受的话，就是在 Endless Thread 的动态中找到这些剧集并收听它们。第一集今天发布。它由制作人弗兰妮·莫纳汉带给我们。嘿，弗兰妮。
Hello. So, Franny, what journey are you taking us on with this side quest? Well, you could say that my side quest is pretty character-driven, as in it's about characters. Like any good movie or piece of fiction, they're all character-based in the end, aren't they? Yeah, and specifically, this story is about the characters you get to design yourself in games. So their body, their clothes, their skills, and it's about how creating a character and playing as that character can be a really powerful way to explore your own character, IRL, your identity. My mom and my brother specifically were asking, like, why do you spend so much time with this game? Why is it so important that you play this character?
你好。那么，弗兰妮，这次支线任务你要带我们踏上怎样的旅程呢？嗯，你可以说我的支线任务非常注重角色，也就是说它关乎角色。就像任何好电影或小说一样，它们到头来都是以角色为基础的，不是吗？是的，具体来说，这个故事关乎你在游戏中自己设计角色的过程。他们的身体、衣服、技能，它关乎创造一个角色并扮演该角色如何成为探索你自身角色、现实生活中的身份的一种非常强大的方式。我的妈妈和弟弟特别问过，为什么你在这个游戏上花这么多时候？为什么扮演这个角色对你如此重要？
And I said, because I get to be beautiful. It wasn't about a peak physical beauty that I wanted. I just wanted to feel good about myself. I wanted to feel at home in my body. Oh, that sounds so cool. I cannot wait to listen. Yeah, and you can listen to that story right now on the Endless Thread feed. And coming up Tuesday on Hidden Levels, our fifth episode,
我说，因为我可以变美。这无关我想要的某种外表上的巅峰美丽。我只是想对自己感觉良好。我想在自己的身体里感到自在。哦，听起来太棒了。我等不及要听了。是的，你现在就可以在 Endless Thread 的动态中收听这个故事。接下来周二在 Hidden Levels 上线的是我们的第五集，
how video games shape our natural world. I could build my house on a beach. I can build my house in a rainforest, you know. I can't do that in real life. This episode was produced by Andrew Callaway, edited by Chris Barube, mixed by Martine Gonzalez, fact-teching by Laura Bowler. Original music by Swan Real, Jamila Sondoto, and Paul Vitkis. The super cool music by Swan and Paul for Hidden Levels is being released as an album.
电子游戏如何塑造我们的自然世界。我可以把我的房子建在海滩上。我可以把我的房子建在雨林里，你知道的。我在现实生活中做不到这一点。本期节目由安德鲁·卡洛维制作，克里斯·巴鲁贝剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，劳拉·鲍勒负责事实核查。原创音乐由 Swan Real、贾米拉·桑多托和保罗·维特基斯创作。Swan 和保罗为 Hidden Levels 创作的超级酷的音乐将作为专辑发行。
You can listen everywhere you stream music. Special thanks to Anna Hanks, Dr. Henry Lowood, and Mateo Batanti. The managing producer for Hidden Levels is Chris Rubé. Hidden Levels was created by me, Ben Brock Johnson, while fleeing a Lionel on the way to Level 9 Death Mountain in Zelda. With power-ups and cheat codes, thanks to Team 99% Invisible and Team Endless Thread. Endless Thread is a production of WBUR, Boston's NPR. The rest of our team tackling Unsolved Mysteries, Untold Histories, and Other Wild Stories from the Internet includes
你可以在任何流媒体音乐平台上收听。特别感谢安娜·汉克斯、亨利·洛伍德博士和马特奥·巴坦蒂。Hidden Levels 的执行制作人是克里斯·鲁贝。Hidden Levels 由我——本·布罗克·约翰逊在前往《塞尔达传说》死亡山第 9 级途中逃离莱尼尔时创建。感谢 99% Invisible 团队和 Endless Thread 团队提供的能量道具和秘籍。Endless Thread 是波士顿 NPR 电台 WBUR 的制作节目。我们团队的其他成员致力于解决未解之谜、不为人知的历史和来自互联网的其他狂野故事，包括
my illustrious co-host, Amory Severson, managing producer Selma To Joshi, editor Meg Kramer, producers Dean Russell, Grace Tatter, and Franny Monaghan, and sound designer, Emily Jankowski. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Kathy. Kirk Colstead is the digital director Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Fabian Leigh, Lodgeman, Lange, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence.
我杰出的联合主持人艾莫里·西弗森，执行制作人塞尔玛·托·乔希，编辑梅格·克雷默，制作人迪恩·拉塞尔、格蕾丝·塔特和弗兰妮·莫纳汉，以及声音设计师埃米利·扬科夫斯基。99% Invisible 的执行制作人是凯西。柯克·科尔斯特德是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂、埃met 菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、法比安·莱、洛奇曼·兰格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森博格以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。99% Invisible 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。
The art for this series was created by Aaron Nestor. We are part of the Serious XM Podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora Building, in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. We'll see you for a new episode of Hidden Levels on Tuesday. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特创作。我们是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区的奥克兰美丽的住宅区奥克兰市中心的潘多拉大厦。我们周二的 Hidden Levels 新节目再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。